coming up next they'll go and diss my ex
what who are they gonna dis next huh you
don't think women should vote yeah
that's a whole nother convo who's your
favorite rapper don't tell me you were a
culture no please don't why do you have
beef with you I don't know if we're
gonna vote then I think we should be
equally drafted into Selective Service
like why should someone like that
doesn't pay into the system have to have
a say on the system that they're not
paying into it no they're not like we
are not fined three hundred thousand
dollars if we do not sign up for
Selective Service men are
so my question is is that fair yes or no
me
wrong you see you have too much of a
female audience huh you can